[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Also, this episode is the
answer to the ultimate question
of life, the universe,
and everything.
So we've got that going for us.
Tango-enabled apps,
like WayfairView,
make it easy to
visualize and rearrange
new furniture in your home.
To learn more about
their app and see
how Tango apps help power
new AR shopping experiences,
check out the posts linked
in the description below.
The Google VR SDK 1.0
with support for Daydream
has graduated out
of beta and is now
available on the
Daydream developer site.
The updated SDK simplifies
common VR development tasks
and supports integrated
asynchronous reprojections,
high fidelity spacialized
audio, and interactions
using the Daydream controller.
To learn more and get
links to the docs, samples,
and tutorials, head
on over to the post.
Android Studio 2.2 is
out of preview and now
available to download
in the stable channel.
For more info and screenshots
on the layout editor,
improved C++ support, and other
top highlights take a look
at the post.
The latest version of our
image captioning system
is now available as an open
source model in TensorFlow.
This release contains
significant improvements
to the computer vision component
of the captioning system,
is much faster to
train, and produces
more detailed and accurate
descriptions compared
to the original
system, which actually
tied for first place in a 2015
image captioning challenge.
For details and the GitHub
link, head on over to the post.
AdMob's Native Ads Express
is a quick and simple way
to set up and monetize your
Native Ads effectively.
Take a look at the post
where three developers share
their success stories
of switching to Native
and growing both their
revenue and their business.
With the new direct
integration between Particle,
and IoT cloud platform and
hardware provider, and Google
Cloud Platform, you can now
easily bring your IoT data
to big data tools,
such as Google Cloud
Dataflow and Google BigQuery.
One of the coolest
cloud integrations
with the new Firebase
platform is the ability
to export raw data
from Firebase Analytics
to Google BigQuery
for custom analysis.
To see what you can do
with this combination,
along with some code,
check out the post.
Speaking of big data,
historical daily weather
from the global
historical climate network
is now available
in Google BigQuery.
The data comes from
over 80,000 stations
in 180 countries,
spans several decades,
and has been quality checked
to ensure that it's temporally
and spatially consistent.
Take a look at the post for some
code and graphs to get started.
Cross-platform map
styling is here.
You can change the color
palette of your maps,
hide labels, vary road density,
and toggle points of interest.
Which means your maps can now
match your brand and style
across your website
and your apps,
using the same
JSON style object.
Oh, and there's a video.
Take a look by jumping over
to the post, linked below.
Please take a moment
to subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]